que ce soit dans touche pas à mon poste
ou sur balance mon poste il est
d'habitude de donner la parole à tout le
monde sur nos plateaux mois la parole
ici elle est ouverte à tout le monde ce
soir dans balances ton post nous allons
revenir sur les actions anti migrants
menée par l'association génération
identitaire une association très
controversé dont le mouvement est
emmenée par taille et ce dès ce qu'ils
font et à qui nous avons décidé de
donner la parole ce soir pour nourrir le
débat comme d'autres émissions ont déjà
pu le faire il semblerait pourtant que
cette invitation ne passe pas auprès
tout le monde et que certains appellent
au boycott alors associations
extrémistes dans balances ton post
doit-on invité tout le monde
doit-on invité tout le monde et avant
que vous donnez votre réponse je
voudrais on vous a fait petit conflit
parce qu'on a reçu beaucoup de critiques
sur les réseaux sociaux des bien
pensants des donneurs de leçons comme
d'habitude pourtant nous ne sommes pas
les premiers à avoir invité ce
groupuscule sur un plateau de télé
plusieurs chaînes l'ont déjà fait avant
nous regarder voilà et souvent sans leur
en poser un détracteur ou à la mise à
part le journaliste voilà qui étaient là
ont une interview au pot voilà qui était
seul regarde on a décidé aujourd'hui
nous jeunes mouvements politiques de
jeunesse de rassembler nos forces je
fais cette petite vidéo c'est pour vous
dire que avec mes treize autres
camarades on vient de sortir du
commissariat et finalement y'a pas il ya
peu de garde à vue y a pas eu de
poursuites non plus ça va et croma
bonjour aux mains porte parole de
générations identitaire vous avez vu que
miss de l'intérieur a dit que c'était de
la gesticulation ce que vous avez fait
un on est on est une grosse dizaine a
tourné à se relayer sur sur zone donc
deux équipes deux équipes qui tournent
afin de afin de quadriller la zone et
d'oeufs et de farine de présence alors
oui non faut-il inviter tout le monde
faut-il inviter cette association soit
je vous pose la question bien sûr chez
vous et je vous donnerai s'est invité
surprise qui vient de se rajouter là il
ya un instant qui verra par milou gardez
bien vos petites pancartes les chéris
s'il vous plaît guillaume genton
pourquoi les questions ont la pause que
quand ces balances ton post cancer en
cinq ans et libération quand c'est tmc
on dit rien puisqu elle sous-entendu que
vous savez pas traiter le sujet que vous
allez mal traité le sujet moi pardon
balances ton post s'est équilibrée à
chaque fois il ya des personnes pour il
ya des personnes contres et moi pardon
mais à chaque fois que je vois des
dérapages sur des sujets d'actualité
c'est sur les chaînes info pseudo
sérieuse il ya pas longtemps sur lci
j'ai vu un un mini se faire insulter par
les n'importe comment et ses soi-disant
les grandes rédactions et des grands
jours
balances ton post c'est bien fait
j'étais pas salariat des journalistes
sur lci si moi je veux dire c'est nous
mais je vous dis je
j'étais inquiète le taf au mans voilà à
montréal et ils font un très maigre mais
évidemment mais ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est parce que c'est
vous parce que ces balances ton post on
sous-entend que les sujets sont
maltraités c'est pas vrai il n'ya jamais
ou très rarement de dérapage dans
balances ton post les intervenants ils
sont bien choisis ils sont légitimes
lassé des gens qui font parler d'eux ils
sont dans l'actualité donc évidemment
qu'il faut en parler
delphine dit non madame film oui parce
que parce que vous êtes une émission de
grande écoute et c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment c'est déjà bouillant entre les
genres tu ne pourrais pas rajouter de
l'huile sur le feu bien que ce soit très
intéressant où j'avais raison que je
comprends que les gens ils peuvent dire
bah voilà en ce moment on n'a pas envie
de ça c'est un peu comprend clé parce
que votre argument maintenant comme
cette semaine c'est vrai qu'ils sont
vraiment dans l'actu puisque vous le
savez qu'ils empêchent des migrants de
rentrer en faisant une barrière humaine
voilà actuellement
voilà donc dans les montagnes donc c'est
vrai que c'est en ce moment tout le
monde en parle et ils font quand même en
parler il faut peut-être leur expliquer
aussi que certaines choses à ce sont
cette saison des jeunes voilà qui
pourrait expliquer certaines choses
bernard montiel et puis non moi je
trouve ça très bien que les amitiés
parce qu'au contraire il faut démonter
leur dire leur propos il faut absolument
qu'ils aient des contradicteurs c'est ce
que vous faites dans cette émission très
bien et tant mieux que vous les ayez
invités moi je dis bravo et je vais être
passionné je vais écouter parce que je
veux voir un peu leurs arguments il faut
il faut leur donner la parole à tous ces
gens là c'est normal vous dire si on
leur donne pas la parole façon ils
apprennent et au contraire ils font des
actions
oui moi je pense qu'au contraire ici
mais peut-être le moment de leur dire de
défauts qu'il faut peut-être arrêter les
conneries oui parce qu'ils ont un
discours qui est parfaitement aux békés
qui est extrêmement efficace donc si on
les laisse parler seul c'est encore plus
dangereux qu'il faut absolument qu'ils
s'expriment qui disent qu'ils ont à dire
et qu'il conte démonte point par point
ce qu'ils sont en train de dire que
sinon c'est beaucoup plus dangereux
on le sait si rené c'est comme ça que
connaissent les grands mouvance il n'y a
pas de contradiction c'est une
catastrophe aurait mon rythme a jugé
qu'il dit non bah non parce qu'en fait
alors j'entends vos arguments
effectivement en plus vous avez en face
d'eux des contradicteurs et des
éditorialistes de grande qualité
ouais mais donc ça évidemment mais je
pense que moi c'est totalement stériles
et inutiles je pense qu'aujourd'hui
d'abord les extrémistes gangrène les
réseaux sociaux et je pense que la télé
doit faire mieux que ça
donc ma lance ton post et toutes les
autres et toutes les autres émissions
de la même manière à l'époque
essentiellement mardi il ya de
nombreuses années il y avait des bastons
régulière c'était la télé du clash télé
jeux du cirque
quand il y avait des révisionnistes face
à des victimes de la shoah et on
attendait la baston est ce que ça à
éviter par exemple que le rassemblement
national soit au deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles je ne le crois
pas je pense qu'en fait les extrémistes
ne font pas avancer le débat et inviter
les extrémistes pour en parler avec eux
ne fait pas avancer le débat
je pense que ce soir devant notre télé
même si je vais regarder par curiosité
pas pour évoluer idéologiquement
je pense qu'en fait je vais je vais pas
me dire ouh là là mais peut-être que
cette petite thaïs est la raison
peut-être dans ce qu'il dit ou non n'ont
heureusement que karim zéribi a dit ça
parce que finalement c'est une d'accord
avec la petite thaïs et on n'en n'ont
finalement karim m'a convaincu donc je
pense que c'est en fait c'est ce que
vous comprenez ce déferlement sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'on les invite à
ben ça c'est parce que c'est vous
bâtiment est parce qu il ya une série
mais moi je trouve que les invités dans
l'absolu c'est inutile mais à l'époque
rappelez vous j'étais contre le ses
invitations des black blocks je pense
que d'ailleurs ça n'a servi à rien après
on les voit donc cesser de la télévision
s'est passé que télégénique c'est un
spectacle mais on sait aussi ce qu'il
faisait mais je veux que tu sois
président 3 la parole aux extrémistes en
france alors bon raymond hénault après
je vous aurais la parole vous inquiétez
pas isabelle nicolas vous aurez tous la
parole ne vous inquiétez pas j'aimerais
qu'on écoute mon rêvons pas ça la
dernière partie de touche pas ou pas ce
n'est pas tout
les mêmes jingle pour vous c'est
magnifique magnifique ne fallait pas non
moi ce que je dis d'abord c'est pas par
rapport à vous on sait dès que vous
faites un truc tout le monde vient vous
taper dessus
vous l'avez dit à l'heure c'est vienne -
quand tu es d'un boulanger il ya moins
de gens qui vient de te taper dessus moi
j'ai moins d'articles c'est sûr qu'il y
en a qui avons un tweet alors moi je
pour répondre à la question je suis
contre pas contrebalançant pas je suis
content toutes les émissions de télé
pour moi on ne doit pas invité ces gens
là on peut pas monter des associations
comme ça pour attendre des migrants à
une frontière taper des migrants les
renvoyer dans l'eau sur leur bateau bien
sûr c'est exactement grave mais on peut
pas faire ça j'ai entendu je mets au
conditionnel
on m'a dit des ces gens là vont dans la
rue et on lève le voile des femmes
je puisse je sais pas si c'est la valeur
monte au conditionnel
on peut pas inviter des gens qui font ça
on peut pas dire à ses dires donner une
tribune à ces gens de dire ces gens là
existent ces gens là doivent race est
devant la justice parce que ce qu'ils
font c'est illégal s'appelle du sac des
choses qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas
clairs ce et c'est puni par la loi
donc ces gens là doivent passer devant
la justice monsieur darmana à 10 ou une
association il n'y a pas non plus à la
baisse et d'autres maladies sous de
cette association est ce qu'il faut là
moi je dis oui oui vous faites répondre
vous chers idiot à ce que regarde on a
on a on a aidé de nombreux mais des
bulls et on va être peut-être ce jeune
homme puisse dire en les faisant passer
dans balances ton post en ayant une
caisse de résonance comme balance mon
poste mais est-ce que ça va pas aussi
réveillé les autorités parce que si on
se rend compte vraiment que tout ce
qu'on dit sur eux et tout ce qu'ils font
est vrai est ce qu'on va pas s'en servir
justement demain pour dire au
gouvernement
regardez est-ce qu'il faudra 10 août
cette association comme ils l'ont fait
où ils ont démantelé barcella démontre
aussi incertaine s'ils passent
exactement alors je rends mais une
deuxième lame s'est quand même
dramatique nous en france on a les
services secrets on a une police on a
des gens qui font des enquêtes qui
savent où sont les gens il faut attendre
balances ton poste pour que dissoudre in
a former une association comme ça c'est
pour moi c'est une association qui est
dangereuse et le fait de donner de
l'exposition ça que j'ai mise maintenant
peut-être que tu amènes d'autres gens à
dire ah bah ils ont raison moi je crois
plus en rien je vais les rejoindre
maintenant c'est ça qui me dérange moi
là dedans il avait certainement tracy
ses complexes a alors d'abord moi je dis
ça c'est pas de la blague assez simple
l'argument de
l'argument de la halle fixé deuxième
film est un roman je suis si choqué par
deux choses quand on est con coup c'est
nous comparer coucou c'est nous et
balances ton poste par dont l'un est un
divertissement noté dans ses émissions
de débat critiqué par les jurés l'ont
manifestement ne la regarde pas et
raymond quand tu dis je sais pas si
c'est vrai je sais pas si c'est pas vrai
par raison plus de les inviter
parce que là il ya des vrais
contradicteurs et en plus c'est là qu'on
voit ça vienne vu encore vrai visage et
leur enquête raymond tous les
chroniqueurs l'armée enquêtait les
étoiles assisté des journalistes et les
gens soient celles de gens à qui vous
donnez pas la parole
il ya des gens ont le yawl de la parole
à tous moi alors je vais bien je te
tutoie peut-être tu donnes apparaîtront
jet d'eau nettoie par exemple dieudonné
qui raconte des conneries on ne donne
pas la parole
et pourtant il ya des gens qui volent en
temps mais justement alors justement
quand il s'établissait justement je
voulais amasser lardy vous trompez c'est
là où les missions que son barça qui
dans les penguins
parce que justement il n'arrive pas à
arrêter ce groupuscule parce qu'ils sont
dans la loi aujourd'hui ça leur pose un
énorme problème et ça pose un énorme
problème au ministre de l'intérieur aux
autorités parce que tout ce qu'ils font
ils sont extrêmement mal un lumix g
touré 6 extrêmement rodez et soulignent
ils ne sont pas hors la loi donc
justement c'est ça le gros bon élève
avec ce groupuscule nicolas pernikoff
alors j'écoute géraldine sur les réseaux
sociaux
clairement aujourd'hui il ya plus de
réponse et je dis que la télé n'a jamais
eu autant d'importance aujourd'hui pour
lutter contre les réseaux sociaux est
immonde pour les seconds du je suis pour
ou juge qui contraignent et la
télévision justement c'est cette édition
on dirait que cette émission en direct
elle va permettre aux téléspectateurs de
comprendre le débat
vous parlez de groupuscules oui dans un
monde de racisme d'antisémitisme
il faut que les gens ils comprennent
qu'ils ne sont oui sinon on fait comment
et les gens
les gens ne le perçoit cette émission en
direct alors elle est mort né puisque
dès qu'il a lancé balances ton post mois
cyril c'est beau et chaud qu il ya 15
ans donc tout va bien
mais dès qu'on a lancé balances ton pote
avec des missions étaient mortes parce
que pourquoi cyril à nous la fera une
émission comme ça de ce n'était pas eux
mêmes ces prophètes émission de société
aujourd'hui et il faut des émissions que
ça m'énerve sanaa pour comprendre
pourquoi il ya un tel malaise dans ce
pays il faut que les gens ils puissent
avoir des contradicteurs en face d'eux
et que les gens puissent s'exprimer
donc bien évidemment qu'il faut l'invité
maintenant effectivement ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils ne sont pas hors
la loi donc vous faites comment vous
avez peur vous n'avez pas peur que
justement ça incite des gens à rejoindre
le mouvement non mais je préfère qu'ils
rejoignent le mouvement parce que le
boulot et pdf est peut-être mal fait
d'informations que d'avoir un
groupuscule comme ça qu'ils rampent sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui se construit
doucement vous savez où seul où cela
nous a mené déjà les groupuscules donc
attention soyons prudents et fanny non
justement je pense qu'on leur donne pas
une tribune
on va leur mettre on va les mettre face
à leurs inepties face à la dangerosité
de leurs actes de leurs propos avec une
arme est ici de journalistes c'est l'adn
je voudrais dire il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui nous regardent qui disent
nous on ne connaît pas le rythme en
essais mais voilà ils sont dangereux et
là au moins on va savoir ce qu'ils font
et j'espère qu'à l'issue de cette
émission les choses vont bouger donc ce
n'est pas une région espère c'est pas
une tribune c'est qu'ils seront face à
une armée et on pourra je l'espère les
faire taire je retiendrai aura un objet
- jurado pour dénoncer des choses il
faut les mettre en lumière parce que
sinon de jolis franchement moi je ne le
connaissais pas ce moment est la chine
est pourtant là pour une raison et sait
le ils sont extrêmement actifs
actuellement vous savez ce qu'ils font
dans l'est dans les pyrénées à séoul
jeudi et celle semaine pour castors
louveteaux leur très grave est encore
timide dans un pays exactement
et encore c'est que pour que les choses
avancent et on doit aller justement mais
non c'est non
en respectant la loi le discours est
bien rodé il est efficace et donc pour
que les gens comprennent ce que c'est
réellement il faut forcément un les
faire parler parce que sinon c'est bon
ils vont s'exprimer n'importe comment
et c'est encore pire il a raison nicolas
c'est comme ça que ce que les gros
mouvements nes
moi j'ai l'impression d'être d'abord et
dans le temps oui moi et mon temps je
suis très content que cyril fasse des
choses comme ça je suis très content
qu'à chaque fois qu'il fait un truc que
ce soit pour un boulanger que ce soit
pour un mec qui dort qu'on voit sur m6
qui dort dans un immeuble aucun travaux
à chaque fois comme par hasard ça bouge
à chaque fois il ya des papiers à chaque
fois y associer je suis très content
mais en même temps vous pouvez pas
m'empêcher d'être à l'intérieur de mon
monde de oui-oui scandalisé ou ou
choqués que il fut hippie fifa il puisse
attendre sans qu'on attende que j'ai
même pas parler français faut qu'on
attende cyril hanouna pour dissoudre une
association damas que vous avez
convaincu l'émission je vais la regarder
et c'est très bien que je ne regardais
que m'ont vraiment vous m'avez convaincu
parce que cette émission a va être forte
avec des vrais intervenants mais même en
france il faut attendre que cyril
hanouna fasse un truc comme ça pour des
mecs on enlève des voiles sur la terre
et les gens c'est encore on enlève une
kippa d'un même si vous avez un parcours
est montée longue à venir de sa de
s'arranger nos récents lionel et moi tu
parles du pentax encore c'est encore du
new yorker directs ont mis ces noms déjà
des soutiens quand tu as compris le but
de soi mais j'ai compris j'ai compris on
espère que ras des ministres est bien
loin des gens voilà qui ont recueilli 1
qui ont du pouvoir est derrière nous on
fera le relais et peut-être pour dire
rien seront absolument arrêter ce
groupuscule je vous le dis il prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur et ça devient
dangereux surtout en ce moment
et là alors il ya plein de gens voilà je
vous dis sur les réseaux sociaux tous
les donneurs de leçons à qui se
permettent d'écrire des papiers sur eux
qui voient là mais qui ne font rien nous
on a décidé ce soir au contraire
d'essayer de faire quelque chose essayer
de les mettre devant leurs
contradictions essayé peut-être de dire
à la fin de cette émission est ce que ça
va bouger pose est-ce qu'on va les
surveiller encore plus est ce qu'on va
essayer de les dissoudre et essayer de
trouver la faille dans ce groupe puisque
c'est ce qu'on espère en tout cas à la
fin de cette émission oui et aura plus
la télé c'est pas le monde des
bisounours ont pas donné que la parole
aux gentils sinon il y aura des bas ce
qu'ils font c'est absolument un femme
est absolument ignobles et moi
journalistique manger envie de
comprendre d'où vient cette haine qu est
ce qui nourrissait elle est sûre si vous
regardez bas peut faire avancer les
choses
si ça peut accélérer la dissolution de
deux groupuscules c'est très bien ça
fait avancer les choses et c'est une
réalité
triste réalité mais pour parler quand
y'a des émissions sur des grands
criminels qui ont fait des choses
ignobles
parfois il ya des interviews ça fait
beaucoup à l'étranger notamment on a
envie de comprendre d'où vient cette
haine c'est important d'en parler aussi
sinon c'est aseptisé en fait oui bernard
ils sont toujours à la limite de la loi
tous accès bien sûr et c'est une
véritable organisation paramilitaire
c'est incroyable il s'habille tout de la
même façon d'ailleurs on a mieux vos
images tout à l'heure alors certes ils
sont tous en bleu pareil c'est vraiment
militaire est super organisé est
toujours à la limite de la loi c'est
pour ça que c'est très dur de deux de
ses plus efficace d'accueillir et de
contredire que d'interdire interdire
comment comment connaître savoir si vous
les ou si vous laissez pas parler
laisser parler c'est effectivement
comprendre le danger je veux monter une
association et moi demain je vais alors
je te donne un exemple pardon pardonnez
moi vraiment pardonnez moi je vais
monter une association demain cheveux
d'un exemple raconte c'est très con ce
que je vais dire j'aime pas les chinois
je montais de l'association pour dire
aux gens vers la loi normale hors la loi
dans ce que je veux c'est me voir je
vais rester dans les clous tu ne peux
pas dire non je vais tout faire en sorte
que tout seul et il faut prévoir
s'appelle génération identitaire et ils
ont dit marie lieu d'oeuvrer pour leur
pays voilà donc là ils essaient de la
loire c'est pas à eux de décider si les
migrants rentrer en france ou s'il ne
rentre pas il ya la loi peuvent s'avérer
ce qu'ils prêchent éviter les gens là
ont besoin chaîne humaine
ils sont inattaquables mais pour raymond
nous si tu dis tu fais cette association
hockey et ben ça remue donc là pour te
dire ce que tu fais c'est de la merde
que tu fais tu n'as pas le droit
et justement on va dénoncer ce que tu
fais on va pas l'applaudir mais c'est
mal de ski pas d'accord ce soir je suis
content je me répète je suis très
content qu'il fasse cette émission et
c'est tout à son honneur et moi je kiffe
balances ton passe parce que c'est en
direct
il n'y a pas de pipeau on va parler on
va répondre tu vas dire une chose il est
vrai je vais te répondre
c'est ça que je kiffe dans cette
émission c'est pas les émissions pipeau
hausse enregistrée on coupe on recoupe
jeu j'aime ça j'aime ça sauf que tu peux
pas m'empêcher de croire moi que une
association aussi dangereuses comme ça
l'état français
mon pays que j'aime plus que tout ils
attendent après cyril hanouna pour
interdire des choses mais c'est
l'expérience en plus on l'a vécu c'est
vrai ce qui se passe à chaque fois qu'il
fait un truc
madame aicha pas qui m'a appelé il ya
lui qui m'appelait et les choses elle
bouge c'est ça que je trouve
j'ai rien contre bas
garder mais bon c'est embêtant c'est en
le mettant à la lune génial pays
missiles à d l'addition est éliminé
c'est d'éduquer c'est d'informer
c'est ce qui fait une demande la tv la
télé ne le fait plus aujourd'hui oui ça
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'ont pensé les
spectateurs je veux dire qui est
l'invité surprise qui va dire oh oui à
65% non à 35 a dit yassine belattar mon
ami ce soir il m'a appelé il ya un
instant il m'a dit mon ciré est ce que
je peux passer je dis bien entendu ça
sera toujours ouvert pour toi donc ce
soir balance mon poste ça va s'enchaîner
direct après touche pas à mon poste et
j'espère que vous serez au rendez vous
en tout cas on espère qu'on va vous
apprendre des choses qu'on va essayer de
faire bouger les choses en grand cette
session en direct et d'essayer de monter
c'est un boulet juste un mot mais
raymond c'est ce qu'on est en train
depuis le début ils sont toujours les
limites de la loi on peut pas leur
interdire est évidemment qu'ils sont
surveillés par les services secrets
évidemment on attend il assure ne le
faut pas pour mieux asseoir mois sites
interdits les migrants tu te substituer
à la loi tu joues aux policiers de
service et c'est celle d'une femme qui
est ok vous allez à cocody sionnel parce
que je ne suis pas sûr que cette info si
tu enlèves le voix d'une femme tu n'es
pas hors-la-loi rare est de me dire ça
arrête de me dire ça tu oses tu es hors
la loi